- 「量子情報と計算の理解」に
戻ってきた。
私はJohn Watrousで、IBM Quantum Educationの
テクニカルディレクターだ。
これはシリーズの第3回目のレッスンだ。最初の2回では、
量子情報の基礎について話した。
まず孤立した単一システムについて、次に複数システムについて扱った。
また、単一および複数システムの設定において、
標準基底測定とユニタリ演算についても議論した。
このレッスンでは、量子計算を記述するための標準的な方法を与えてくれる
quantum circuit modelを紹介する。
またquantum circuitを使って、量子プロトコルや複数の量子デバイスが関わる
その他の種類の相互作用を記述することもできる。
quantum circuitに加えて、量子情報と関連する
いくつかの重要な数学的概念についても議論する。
そしてそれらを使って、量子情報とquantum circuitで
できることの基本的な限界をいくつか観察していく。
それによって次のレッスンの準備が整う。
次のレッスンではいくつかの非常に重要な例を見て、
シリーズの第1ユニットを締めくくることになる。
量子情報の基礎について。
レッスンの概要はこうだ。まずquantum circuit modelから始めて、その仕組みを見ていく。
次に、内積という非常に重要な概念、
そして正規直交性と射影について話す。
これらは内積と関連している。最初の2回のレッスンでこれらを議論しなかったのは、
本当に必要なかったからだが、今は必要だ。
内積は、なくてはならない数学的ツールを
提供してくれる。
内積なしでは、量子情報と計算の理解において
まったく先に進めない。
そしてレッスンの第3部では、量子情報の
いくつかの重要な限界を見ていく。
最終的にやりたいのは、量子情報でできる面白いことを
探求することだが、それを効果的に行うためには、
できないことも
いくつか知っておく必要がある。
特に、グローバル位相という概念と、
グローバル位相がなぜ無関係なのかを議論する。
量子状態は一般にコピーできないということを
教えてくれるno-cloning定理の主張を見る。また、2つの量子状態は
直交していない限り、互いに完全に
識別できないことも見る。これは認識すべき基本的な
限界だ。
レッスンの最初のトピックは
quantum circuit modelだ。これは計算のモデルで、
方法を提供してくれる。
量子計算を記述するための。
quantum circuit modelは、コンピュータサイエンスにおける
circuitのより一般的な概念に基づいており、
多くの異なる計算モデルを定義できる。
この一般的な概念に基づいて。
基本的な考え方は、circuitは情報を運ぶワイヤと、
演算を表すgateで構成されているということだ。
ワイヤが運ぶ
情報に適用される演算。
circuitという用語は、実は
このようなモデルに使うのはちょっと奇妙な名前だ。
なぜならcircuitという言葉は
通常、何らかの
循環経路を指すからだ。
しかし計算のモデルとしてcircuitについて話すとき、
通常は非巡回circuitのことを
指している。
循環経路が許されない。
より正確に言えば、このシリーズの目的のために、
どのcircuitにおいても情報は常に
左から右に流れると定める。
だから好みによっては、circuitを
時間が左から右に進む操作の列を記述するものとして
考えることもできる。
これはブール回路の例で、ワイヤはゼロかイチかの
2進数の値を運び、
gateはブール論理演算を
表している。
ワイヤは線で表され、ここではXとYとラベル付けされた
2つの入力ビットがある。
特定の入力の選択に対してcircuitが何をするかを知りたければ、
ワイヤ上の値を左から右に
伝播させる。
ワイヤが運ぶ値に
gateが作用する内容に
従って。
例えば、上の入力ワイヤを値イチに、
下の入力ワイヤを値ゼロに設定した場合に
何が起きるかを見ることができる。
これらの2つの入力ワイヤは、ここにある
2つのドットに繋がっており、それらはファンアウト演算を表している。
つまり値がコピーされる。
複数のワイヤに沿って
先へ運べるように。
これを行うと、これらの2つのワイヤはこのイチと同じ値イチを取り、
これらの2つのワイヤはこのゼロと同じ値ゼロを取る。
このゼロと同じ。
ここにNOT gateがあり、論理否定の記号で示されているので、
出てくる値はゼロだ。
イチの論理否定だ。同様に、このgateから出てくる値はイチで、
ゼロの論理否定だ。
これらの2つのgateはAND gateで、
このgateはOR gateだ。続けて値を
伝播させると
circuit を通じて、各 gate を適切に評価していくと、
このワイヤの最終的な値は1になるのがわかる。
つまり、circuit 全体は、
図が示すように合成された一連の演算を表しており、
最終的に2ビットから1ビットへの関数が得られる。
この特定の例ではそうだが、一般的には
入力・出力のビット数はいくつでもあり得る。
この circuit は2つの入力ビットの排他的論理和を計算するもので、
出力が1になるのは、
2つの入力ビットのうちの一方だけが1で
もう一方が0の場合に限られる。ただし、それは
本質的な話じゃない――単なる例だ。
Boolean circuit に関する基本的な事実として、
任意のビット数から任意のビット数への関数は、
何らかの Boolean circuit で計算できる。
ただし、興味のある関数を計算するには
非常に大きな circuit が必要になる場合もある。
circuit を表現するには
他のスタイルも使われている。
例えば、この図は
先ほどとまったく同じ circuit を、電気工学でより一般的なスタイルで表したものだ。
そこでは、異なる gate を表す図形の形に
慣習がある。
このスタイルは使わないが、
Hadamard gate や Controlled NOT gate など、
量子 gate ごとに独自の記号を導入していく。
Toffoli gate なども同様だ。
余談だが、ここで「circuit」という言葉の
語源がわかる。
電気工学の文脈では、電気が
circuit を循環するというイメージは非常に自然だ。
だがこのシリーズでは、circuit を流れるのは
電気じゃなく、情報の話をしている。
そして、ここでも circuit は常に非循環的で、
情報は左から右へと流れる。
次は、算術 circuit と呼ばれる
別の種類の circuit の例だ。
今度はワイヤが数を格納し、gate は
加算や乗算といった算術演算を表す。
ここに算術 circuit の例がある。
このレッスンでは何を計算するかは重要じゃない。
これは単に、circuit にはさまざまな概念があるということを
伝えるための例だ。
確率的な演算を gate が表すような、
ランダム性を含む circuit についても考えられる。
もし望むなら、
circuit の概念に基づいた新しい計算モデルを
一日中夢想することもできるだろう。
quantum circuit モデルでは、
ワイヤは qubit を表し、gate はユニタリ演算と測定の両方を表す。
これは量子 circuit の非常にシンプルな例だ。
この circuit には qubit が1つだけあり、
水平線で表されている。そして gate は
四角形で示されており、
この qubit に対して行われるユニタリ演算を表す。
この例には測定は含まれていない。
qubit にXという名前をつけたい場合は、
図の中でここにXと記載することで示せる――これは任意だ。
先ほどの Boolean circuit と同様に、この circuit も
時間が左から右へ進む一連の演算として考えることができる。
つまり、Xからスタートして、
最初の gate として Hadamard gate を適用し、
続いてS gate を適用する。
次にもう一つの Hadamard gate、
そして最後にT gate だ。
これらの演算はレッスン1の終盤で見たもので、
ここでその行列表現を確認できる。
この4つの演算をH、S、H、Tの順に
実行すると、
その合成演算はここに示す積で与えられる。
ただし、レッスン1で話したように
順序が本質的に逆になることに注意。
行列の積を計算すると、この行列が得られる。
つまり、qubit Xに対するこの circuit の作用は、
このユニタリ行列で表される。
量子 circuit の図に、入力として何を与えるかを
明示したい場合もある。ここに示すようにすればできる。
この場合、circuit にKet 0を入力している。
これはよくあることだ。Ket 0 を qubit の初期化状態とすることが多いが、
必ずしもそうである必要はない。
circuit を別の状態に適用することも
考えられる。
必要であれば、得られる出力状態を
このように示すこともできる。
次の例では、図からわかるように
XとYという2つの qubit がある。
ここには Hadamard gate があり、qubit Yに適用される。
続いてこのシンボルで示される gate がある。
これは Controlled NOT gate だ。Controlled NOT 演算については
前のレッスンで話した。
この図では、制御 qubit はYで、
小さな塗りつぶされた丸で示されている。
ターゲット qubit はXで、
プラス記号のように見える大きな丸で示されている。
排他的論理和の記号に似ているから、
理にかなっている。
YにストアされたどんなクラシカルなStateも、qubit XにXORされると想像できる。
明確にするために、このgateの標準基底Stateへの作用を示す図がある。
AとBはバイナリ値だと
仮定する。
その他のStateに対しては、作用は
いつも通り線形性によって決まる。
先に進む前に、Qubitsの順序付けに関して
従う規則を明示しておくと便利だ。
この例のようなquantum circuit図の中での話だ。
規則としては、quantum circuit図での
下から上の順序は、左から右への順序と等価だ。
タプルやテンソル積と同じようにね。
それはこのシリーズで従う規則で、
Qiskitでも使われている規則だ。
だからこの特定のcircuitは、
qubit X、Yのペアに作用すると考える。
Xが一番下にあるから最初に来て、Yはこの場合一番上にあるから最後、または2番目に来る。
視覚的に理解しやすい方法として、
このcircuitを時計回りに回転させて、入力が上に
出力が下にくるよう想像してみると、
qubitの順序が正しくなる。
この順序でつまずく人もいるから、
この規則を念頭に置いておくこと。
このcircuitが表す作用について考えると、最初に
Hadamard gateがYに適用される。
そして2つのqubitに対してControlled NOT gateが適用され、
YがコントロールでXがターゲットになる。
この2つのgateの合成作用を表すユニタリ行列を
書き下したいなら、それもできる。
まず、YへのHadamard gateを考える。
YにHadamard gateを適用して、Xには何もしない。
これはXに恒等操作を行うのと等価だ。
だから両qubitまとめたときのHadamard gateの作用は、
恒等行列とHadamard操作を表す行列との
テンソル積で与えられる。
XはYの前に来てYは2番目という
規則を念頭に置くと、こう見える。
つまり恒等行列とHのテンソル積だ。
次にControlled NOT操作を適用する。
この行列表現があって、これも規則と整合している。
2番目のqubit YがコントロールでXが1番目のqubitでターゲットだ。
ビデオを一時停止してこれが正しいか確認するのを
恐れなくていい。もうそれを言わなくてもわかると思うけど。
このビデオを一時停止して、見たい部分を何度でも
見直したり、再生速度を調整したり、自分に合った方法で使ってくれ。
ともかく、2つの操作を合成すると、
合成した作用はここにあるこの積で表される。
この2つの行列はこの順序で掛け合わされる。
Hadamardが最初に行われてControlled NOTが2番目に行われるからだ。
これも再び、レッスン1で話した内容と整合している。
順序は本質的に逆になる。
行列の掛け算を実行すると、ここにこの行列が得られる。
この行列からcircuitが標準基底Stateに
何をするか読み取れる。
circuit を入力0, 0で実行した場合、つまり1番目のqubitにKet 0、2番目のqubitにKet 0を入れると、
結果はPhi+ Bell stateになる。
これは行列の最初の列から確認できる。
0, 1を入れるとPhi- stateになって、1, 0はSi+ stateを与える。
1, 1はPsi-ではなく、-1 x Psi-を与える。
マイナス符号は実はここではそんなに重要じゃない。
これを取り除きたければ、2つのqubitに対してswap操作を行えばいい。
そうすれば最初の3つの標準基底Stateに
起きたことを台無しにせずに済む。
でも今回の例では
本当に重要じゃない。
まとめると、circuitは標準基底Stateに
対してここに示すこの作用を持つ。
特定のcircuitが何をするか考えるとき、
行列への変換をして掛け合わせる必要はない。
特定のStateに対してcircuitが持つ作用を
追いかけることもできる。多くの場合これが好ましい方法だ。
例えばこの例では、gateの作用を調べることで
circuitが0, 0 stateに何をするかわかる。
初期stateはここではPi zeroと名付けた。
Bell stateと紛らわしい名前を避けるためで、0, 0だ。
Hadamard gateを適用すると得られるstateは0+で、
こんな風に展開できる。
そしてControlled NOT操作がこのstateをPhi+ stateへ
変換する。これはControlled NOTが標準基底Stateに対して
持つ作用を考えることで確認できる。
他の3つの標準基底State、あるいは
他のどんなstateについても同じことができる。
quantum circuit図に古典bitを組み込むこともできる。
この図のような二重線で
示される。
AとBは古典bitで、XとYはqubitだ。
前の例と同じ2つのユニタリgateがあって、ここにある記号は標準基底測定を表してる
具体的には、2つの
ユニタリ演算が行われた後、Yに対して
標準基底測定が
行われて、その結果は
古典ビットBに上書きされる。同様に、Xが測定されてその結果がビットAに書き込まれる。
ここで、qubit XとYは測定された後も続いていることがわかる。
とはいえ、測定後の
qubitをそこまで気にしないのは
かなり一般的なことだ。
測定結果だけが
重要な場合もある。そういうケースでは、ここに見えるような省略表記を
使える。qubitが入力として入り、古典ビットが出力として出てくる表記だ。
ここでの理解は、
qubitが測定されたら、それらは単に
捨てられるか無視されて、古典的な測定の
結果だけが引き継がれるということだ。
このシリーズが続くにつれて、quantum circuitの
例をたくさん見ることになるが、それらは通常
今見た非常に単純な例よりも
ずっと複雑になる。
先ほど述べたように、異なる
gateには異なる記号が
使われる。
単一qubit gateは通常、
どの演算かを示す文字が書かれた
四角で表される。
これらの異なるgateが
色分けされて異なる意味を持つ場合もあるが、
今はそれは無視しよう。
Controlled NOT gateは
すでに見た。
Swap gateはここに
見えるように表記される。ToffoliゲートとFredkin gateは
ここに見えるように表記される。
Toffoli gateは制御付きControlled NOT gateで、Fredkin gateは
制御付きswap gateだということを覚えておこう。
つまりこれらの記号は、
制御qubitが実線の丸で表されて、それが制御する
gateまで線で繋がれるという
考え方と一致してる。
一般的に、制御qubitは
上にある必要はないし、これらのgateは
隣接するqubitに作用する必要もない。つまりこれらのgateは
作用しない他のqubitをまたいで伸びることができる。そのことは
今後のレッスンで見ることになる。
quantum circuitモデルを使う際によくやることがもう一つあって、任意のユニタリ演算を見るということだ
任意の数のqubitに対して、
ここに見えるような単一のgateかのように扱う。
どのユニタリ演算かを示すラベルを付けた
四角を描くだけだ。
この場合、何らかの
ユニタリ演算Uだ。
もちろん、この図からは
Uが何なのかはわからない。Uが何らかの形で定義されているか、あるいは任意の
ユニタリ演算Uを考えているのだと仮定するしかない。例えば、
わかりやすくするためにUをサブルーティンとして
考えたい場合もあるだろう。
また、制御U演算に対して
ここに見えるこの表記も使う。制御qubitは以前と
同様に実線の丸で示される。
というわけで、これが
quantum circuitモデルの簡単な入門だ。前にも言ったように、quantum circuitの
例はこれからも
シリーズを続ける中でたくさん見ることになる。
レッスンの次のパートでは、
内積、正規直交性、射影について見ていく。これらは非常に重要な概念だ
量子情報と計算において。
まず内積から始めよう。
ディラック記法を
使う場合、Ketは列ベクトルで
Braは行ベクトルだということを覚えておこう。
そして具体的には、
与えられた列ベクトルに対応する
Braベクトルはその列ベクトルの共役転置だ。
つまりここにあるこのベクトルに対して、対応するBraベクトルを得るには、ベクトルを行列かのように転置し、
つまり横に倒して、それから各要素の複素共役を取る。
では、このように同じ数の要素を持つ2つのKetがあるとしよう。
ここにあるこのブラケットを作ると、それは単に
BraとKetの積を
行列かのように取ることを意味する。
すると、ここに見えるこの式が
得られる。これはスカラー、つまり
複素数だ。
この値はこれら2つのベクトルの
内積と呼ばれる。
内積については、ここに見えるような
形のベクトル、つまりベクトルが
線形結合として表される
標準基底ベクトルの形でも考えられる。
これらのベクトルの内積は以前と
同じように定義される。Bra Psi かけるKet Phiで、これをこのような積として表せる。
計算して簡略化すると、内積に対してここに見えるこの式が残る。これは前と類似してるが、
今回は、この特定のケースでシグマである古典状態集合の要素に対して
和を取ってる点が違う。
これは内積がどのように機能するかについて
幾何学的なイメージを与えるための例だ。
ここにqubitに対応する
2次元空間の円を描いた。実数の要素を持つベクトルに注目する限り、
この平面上の点としてそれらを描ける。
Phiをここにある
このベクトルとしよう。
これは単位ベクトルで、ユークリッドノルムを計算することで確認できる。この円が表しているのもそれで、
実数の成分を持つ
単位ベクトル全体を表している。
次に、Psiをここにある
このベクトルとしよう。これもやはり単位ベクトルだ。
実はこれはマイナス状態だが、ここではPsiと呼ぶことにする。
この2つのベクトルの内積を計算すると、1から√3を2√2で割った値を引いたものになり、
それはおよそ-1/4になる。
この内積の値は、2つのベクトルの間の角度のコサインに等しい。図でも確認できるはずだ。
これは単位ベクトル一般に成り立つことだ。2つの単位ベクトルがどちらも実数の成分を持つなら、
その内積はベクトル間の
角度のコサインに等しくなる。
特に、内積がゼロに等しい場合、たとえばこの例のようにPsiをここにある状態に変えたとき、
2つのベクトルは互いに
90度の角度をなすことになる。
ちなみにこれは任意の次元のベクトルにも一般化できる。成分が実数である限り、2次元ベクトルに限った話ではない。
成分が複素数の場合、この図式はうまく機能しなくなるが、それでも内積は同様に有用だということがわかるはずだ。
内積にはいくつかの重要な性質があり、ここでそのいくつかを少し見ておこう。
まず、内積とユークリッドノルムの間の関係から始める。
任意のベクトルとそれ自身の内積を取ると、ユークリッドノルムの二乗が得られる。
つまり言い換えると、ベクトルのユークリッドノルムは内積の平方根に等しいと言える。
ベクトルとそれ自身の内積の平方根だ。これは偶然ではなく、根本的なつながりであり、内積の定義に
複素共役がなければ、この式は成り立たなくなり、ユークリッドノルムとのこうした有用なつながりも
この根本的な関係も
失われてしまう。
次に、内積は共役対称性を持つ。これは、2つの引数の順序を入れ替えると、内積の値が共役になることを意味する。
これはここに示した式で表され、この2つの式からなぜこうなるかは非常に直感的に理解できる。
2つのベクトルの内積を2通りの順序で計算した場合の式だ。
内積は第2引数に対して線形だ。具体的には、ベクトルPhiをこの2つのベクトルの線形結合として定義すると、
Phi1とPhi2の線形結合として、任意のベクトルPsiとPhiの内積は、2つの内積の同じ線形結合になる。
これは行列の積が線形であるという事実から直接導かれる。
また、内積は第1引数に対して共役線形であることもわかる。これはここに示した式の通りだ。
PsiがベクトルのこのLinear combinationである場合、PsiとPhiの内積を取ると、
ブラPsiはここに示すようなベクトルになり、beta1とbeta2の複素共役を取ることになる。
そしてこれが結果となり、それが共役線形性の意味するところだ。
内積について最後に触れておきたい性質は、非常に有用なCauchy-Schwarz不等式だ。
任意の2つのベクトルPsiとPhiに対して、内積の絶対値は2つのベクトルのユークリッドノルムの積を超えることはない。
さらに、不等式の両辺が等しくなるのは、2つのベクトルが線形従属である場合に限られる。
線形従属とは、一方がもう一方のスカラー倍に等しいことを意味する。
これは数学全体で最もよく使われる不等式の一つであり、量子情報について話す際には繰り返し使うことになる。
だから知っておくととても役に立つ。
次に、内積と関係する直交性と正規直交性の概念について話す。
具体的には、ベクトルの内積がゼロに等しいという条件と関係している。
正確に言うと、2つのベクトルPsiとPhiがあるとき、その内積が
ゼロに等しい場合、それらを直交していると言う。直交ベクトルを直感的にイメージすると、互いに直角をなしている、
あるいは言い換えれば、
互いに垂直だということだ。
「直交する」という言葉が、互いに無関係なものを指すために使われることがある。たとえば、ある問題は別の問題と直交すると言ったりするが、
それは当然かなりインフォーマルな用法であり、数学的な意味では正確ではない。ただ、直交ベクトルが
反対方向ではなく、たとえば北と西のような全く異なる方向を向いていると考えれば、その関連性は明確だ。
ベクトルの集合があるとき、その集合から選んだ任意の2つの異なるベクトルが
必ず互いに直交する場合、その集合を直交集合と言う。ここに示した式で表される通りだ。
正規直交集合とは、
単純に単位ベクトルからなる直交集合のことだ。
直交集合のベクトルは必ずしも
単位ベクトルである必要はなく、実際には
零ベクトルでさえも
直交集合の要素になり得る。だが正規直交集合では、すべてのベクトルが単位ベクトルでなければならない。
それに加えて、
集合が直交集合であるという条件も必要だ。
内積とユークリッドノルムの関係についての知識を使えば、この
条件をかなり簡潔に表現できる。
ちょうどここに見えている通りだ。
そして最後に、正規直交基底とは単純に、
私たちが話題にしているベクトル空間の基底を
なす正規直交集合のことだ。
例えば、古典状態集合シグマを任意に取って、
すべての標準基底ベクトルの集合について考えてみると、
これは正規直交集合であり、実際には、この古典状態集合シグマに対応するエントリを持つすべてのベクトルの空間に対する正規直交基底になっていることがわかる。
これらはすべて単位ベクトルであり、
ペアで直交しているので、正規直交集合だ。
さらに基底でもあるので、正規直交基底だということになる。
ちなみに正規直交集合は常に
線形独立だ。だから正規直交集合があれば、それは常に
何らかの部分空間に対する正規直交基底になる。
ただしこの場合は、私たちが扱っている空間全体に対する基底を持っている。
もう一つの例は、
Ket+とKet-を含む集合だ。
この2つのベクトルは直交しており、内積はゼロに等しい。
そして両方とも単位ベクトルであり、
単一のqubitに対応するベクトルの二次元空間を張るので、その空間に対する正規直交
基底をなす。
もう一つの例はBell基底で、これは2つのqubitに対応する
四次元ベクトルの空間に対する正規直交基底だ。
一方、Ket 0とKet+を含む集合は
直交集合ではない。なぜならこれらのベクトル間の
内積がゼロでないからだ。
どちらも単位ベクトルであり、qubitに対応するベクトル空間の基底になっているが、直交性がない。
正規直交集合について、時々使う便利な事実を紹介しよう。
ベクトルの正規直交集合があるとしよう。具体的には、
この集合にM個のベクトル、Psi 1からPsi Mまでがあるとしよう。
ここでは、これらのベクトルがN次元ベクトル空間から取られていると仮定している。つまり言い換えると、各
ベクトルはMエントリを持つ。
すでに述べたように、正規直交集合は常に
線形独立なので、MがNより大きくなることはあり得ない。
ただしMがNより小さい場合はあり得て、
それが私たちが興味を持っているケースだ。
そしてこの事実が述べているのは、
MがNより小さければ、追加のベクトルを
加えることが常に可能だということだ。
最初の集合に追加することで、
空間の正規直交基底を得られる。
正確に言うと、ベクトルPsi M+1からPsi Nまでが
必ず存在して、コレクション全体が
正規直交基底をなすようにできる。
つまり、正規直交基底に拡張できないような
正規直交ベクトルの集合を選んでしまって
八方塞がりになる、ということは
決してあり得ない。
始めた集合を見て、正規直交基底を形成するように拡張する方法を見つけられることもあるが、常に機能する別の方法もある。
それはGram-Schmidtの
正規直交化法として知られる手順を使って、これらのベクトルを構成することだ。
この手順については、
このレッスンやこのシリーズでは説明しない。具体的な内容は
私たちにとってそれほど重要ではないが、もちろん
気になれば調べることができる。
関連する場合に備えて言っておくと、
コンピュータで実行できる手順だから、
創造性は必要なく、単純な機械的な手順だ。
これがとても便利な事実である理由の一つは、正規直交
基底とユニタリ行列の間に存在する密接な関係に関係している。
特に、任意の正方行列Uに対して、ここに見える3つの条件は常に同値だ。
つまり、すべて真か
すべて偽のどちらかだということだ。
第1の条件は、Uがユニタリ行列であるということで、
これはUダガーかけるUと、UかけるUダガーの両方が
単位行列に等しいことを意味する。
第2の条件は、Uの行が正規直交基底をなすということで、
第3の条件はUの列が
正規直交基底をなすというものだ。
この同値関係が成り立つ理由を理解するのは、
実はそれほど難しくない。
簡単のために、ここに見えるような
3×3行列Uを見てみよう。エントリは
任意の複素数でよい。
ここ左側には、利便のため
Uの共役転置を書いた。
Uの列から3つのベクトルを作ると、
ここではPsi 1、Psi 2、Psi 3と名付けているが、
Uダガーを掛けてUを取ると、
積の各エントリが、ここに見えるこのパターンのように
ベクトルの内積で与えられることを確認できる。
そしてUがユニタリであるという条件、
つまりこの行列が単位行列に等しいという条件について考えると、
それが3つのベクトルが正規直交集合を
なすことと同値だとわかる。
対角エントリはすべて1に等しくなければならないので、これらは必然的に単位ベクトルであり、非対角
エントリはゼロでなければならない。
つまり直交ベクトルの集合だということだ。
UがユニタリであることはUの列が正規直交集合を成すことと同値だ。
そしてそれは基底でなければならない。なぜなら集合内のベクトルの数（この場合は3）が空間の次元と一致するからだ。
今扱っている空間においてだ。列の代わりに行について同様の議論をたどれば、Uがユニタリであることは
行が正規直交基底を成すことと同値だという結論が得られる。
複素共役がうまく機能するように調整が必要なので列の場合ほどきれいにはいかないが、考え方は同じだ。
もう一つの方法として、かなり直接的なやり方がある。それは、行列がユニタリであることとその転置がユニタリであることが同値だと証明することだ。
ここで言いたいのは転置であって共役転置ではないことに注意してほしい。
ユニタリ行列の定義から、任意のユニタリ行列の共役転置がユニタリであることは
ほぼ自明だ。
だが任意のユニタリ行列の転置もユニタリであることもまた事実だ。
いずれにせよ、任意の正方行列Uに対してこれら三つの条件の間に
同値関係があり、この同値関係を
正規直交集合を拡張して正規直交基底を構成できるという事実と組み合わせることで、
面白いことをするユニタリ行列や
様々なニーズを満たすユニタリ行列を作り出せる。
具体的には、M個のベクトルからなる正規直交集合があれば、常に最初のM列がその正規直交集合のベクトルとなるユニタリ行列Uが存在する。
最初のM列がその正規直交集合のベクトルとなるユニタリ行列Uだ。
残りの列は、列が
正規直交基底を成すように選ぶことで常に埋めることができ、ユニタリ行列が得られる。これはかなり
便利な事実だ。
このセクションのもう一つのトピックとして、
射影という概念を扱う。
正方行列Πは、ここに列挙された二つの性質が
両方成り立つとき、射影または射影行列と呼ばれる。
ちなみにこれは大文字のΠで、射影を表す文字としてよく使われる典型的な選択だ。
このような典型的な名前を行列などのオブジェクトに付けることが多いが、それは認識しやすくして混乱を避けるためだ。
好きな名前を使って構わない。いずれにせよ、最初の条件はΠがその共役転置に等しいというものだ。
一般に、行列が自分自身の共役転置に等しいとき、その行列はエルミート行列だと言う。
よって最初の条件は、ΠはエルミートだとE言い換えることもできる。
二番目の条件は、Πを二乗したとき、つまりΠにΠをかけたとき、再びΠが得られるというものだ。
つまりΠを二乗しても何も変わらない。
射影のアイデアを直感的に言えば、像をスクリーンに投影したり線に垂線を下ろしたりすることと
似たようなものだ。
例えばそういったことだ。ベクトルに射影をかけるとき、ある意味で
その一部をそのままにして
残りをゼロにする。
だから射影を二度目に適用しても何もしない。なぜなら射影がゼロにする部分はすでにゼロになっているからだ。
射影の例として、単位ベクトルΨを任意に選んだときのこの行列がある。
必要な条件を一つずつ確認できる。
最初の条件については、共役転置を計算する。これは積の共役転置だ。
なので積の共役転置に関するこの式を使えばいい。
得られるのは共役転置の積だが、順序が逆になる。
それは転置の部分があるからだ。
この式を適用すると、この等式が得られ、それを簡略化すれば
元の行列に戻る。
ちなみに、Ψが単位ベクトルであるという事実は使っていないことに注意してほしい。
実際、この行列は単位ベクトルに限らず任意のベクトルΨに対してエルミートだ。
二番目の条件については、Πを二乗するとこの式が得られ、それは今度は元の行列と等しい。
なぜならΨは単位ベクトルだから、この内積は1に等しく、そこでΨが単位ベクトルだという仮定が
登場する。
この例を一般化して、正規直交集合から始めることができる。
個々のベクトルに対応する射影を足し合わせたこの行列を作ると、射影が得られる。
画面にはそれを明らかにする計算が表示されているが、興味があれば自分で確かめてみてほしい。
最初の例と同様に、集合の正規直交性が使われるのは二番目の条件においてだ。
この射影をベクトルにかけると、そのベクトルをこのベクトルの集合が張る部分空間に射影する。
抽象的に言えば、その部分空間に垂線を下ろすようなもので、一度その部分空間に入ってしまえば射影は何もしない。
つまり、このような行列が射影の例であり、実はここで全ての可能性を
尽くしたことになる。
全ての射影行列は、ある正規直交集合を選ぶとこの形を取る。
零行列は射影なので、全ての射影を得たいなら必ずそれも含めるようにしなければならない。
明確にしておくと、Mがゼロになる可能性も認めており、それによって空の和が生まれる。
これはゼロ行列として解釈できる。
これで射影という概念が手に入ったから、射影測定として知られるより一般的な量子測定のクラスを定義できる。
これは測定の最も一般的な概念ではないが、標準基底測定よりもかなり一般的だ。
量子情報の記述にこれを取り込むのは非常に有益だ。
射影測定は、ここに見られる条件、つまり射影の和が単位行列になるという条件を満たす任意の射影の集合によって定義される。
MはどんなPositiveな整数でも構わない。これらがすべて射影であり、この条件が成立している限り、
その集まりは射影測定を定義する。
そのような集まりによって記述される測定は、任意の量子状態Psiを測定するときに次のように機能する。
まず1からMの間の結果が得られ、MはProjectionの数だ。
各々の可能な結果Kについて、その結果を得る確率は、得られるベクトルのユークリッドノルムの二乗だ。
SにKth projectionであるPi Kを掛けることで得られる。
この量はここに見られる形でも書ける。
この等式は、ユークリッドノルムと内積の関係と、Pi Kがprojectionであるという事実から導かれる。
2番目の形と、これらのprojectionに課した条件から、線形性によって、確率の和が常に1になることがすぐにわかる。
Psiが単位ベクトルでなければならないことを念頭に置いておこう。
次に、結果Kが得られたと仮定すると、系の状態は、射影によって得たベクトルを正規化して得られる量子状態に崩壊する。
すぐにいくつかの例を見ていくが、その前に、可能な結果に1からMまでの番号を付ける必要は実際にはないことを述べておこう。
結果にはどんな名前や記号を使っても構わない。
特に、ガンマと呼ぶある集合の記号でラベル付けされたprojectionの集まりがあれば、
以前と同じ条件、つまりそれらの和が単位行列になるという条件を満たすなら、射影測定となる。
動作は以前とまったく同じだ。
唯一の違いは、測定結果を1からMの整数ではなく、この集合ガンマの要素にすることを許しているという点だ。
射影測定の最初の例として、標準基底測定が射影測定であることを確認しよう。
この場合、測定の結果の集合は、測定される系の古典的状態の集合と同じだ。
測定を記述するprojectionの集合は、シグマが古典的状態の集合だと仮定すると、ここに示す集まりだ。
これらはすべてprojectionであり、それらを足すと単位行列が得られるから、有効な射影測定だ。
もう少し詳しく見るために、ここに示す形で書かれた任意の状態があるとしよう。
先ほどの記述によると、測定が結果Aを与える確率はここに示す値だ。
これはベクトルPsiの対応する成分の絶対値の二乗に等しく、これは期待通りだ。
結果がAであるという条件のもとで、先ほどの記述によれば、系の状態はこうなる。
簡略化すると、期待する状態であるケットAはきちんと得られない。
代わりにケットAにスカラーが掛かったものが得られ、具体的にはこれは絶対値が1のスカラーだ。
つまり単位円上の複素数だ。
これはグローバル位相と呼ばれ、グローバル位相についてはすぐに議論するが、今のところ簡単に言うと、この状態はケットAと等価だ。
このグローバル位相には実際には何の意味もなく、グローバル位相の議論に入ったときにその理由がわかる。
だから、すぐに話すグローバル位相の問題を除けば、標準基底測定は
実際に射影測定であることがわかる。別の例として、これは前の例の拡張だが、
前のレッスンで話したように、系Xに対して標準基底測定を行い、系Yには何もしない場合、
これは系X、Yを測定することと完全に等価だ。
ここに示すこの射影測定を使って。
Xの古典的状態に対応するprojectionがあり、Y上の単位行列でテンソル積を取っている。
これはYには何もしていないという事実を反映している。
射影測定が一般的にどう機能するかの記述が、この例で何が起きるかを教えてくれる。前のレッスンで議論したこととこれが実際に
完全に等価であることを確認するのはあなたに任せる。
これは非常に良い。なぜなら、この射影測定の記述はある意味でよりすっきりしており、それがこのより一般的な枠組みに収まることがわかるからだ。
射影測定のもう一つの例を
見てみよう。
これは二つのqubitの測定だ。
この測定では二つの射影があり、
したがって可能な結果も二つ——
ゼロと一だ。
射影はここで見るように
Bell状態を使って定義される。
最初の射影は三つの対称Bell状態が
張る空間への射影で、
二番目の射影は一次元空間への射影だ。
その一次元空間は反対称なPsi-状態が
張るもので、言い換えれば
二つのqubitにswap操作を行うと
マイナス符号が掛かるものだ。
この測定がなぜ興味深いかは
シリーズの後半で見ていく。
今のところは、以前に見たもの——
Bell基底と結びつく例として
捉えておこう。
射影測定についての最後の注意として、
射影測定があればいつでも
その測定を実装できる。
ユニタリ操作と
標準基底測定を使ってね。
この測定の具体的な例では、
測定を実装するquantum circuitを
ここで見るように構築できる。
上の二つのqubitを
この射影測定で測定するqubitとして
想定して、新しいqubitを
導入することができる。
そのqubitはゼロ状態に初期化された
状態から始まる。Hadamard gateを実行し、
続いてFredkin gate、
そしてまたHadamard gateだ。
この下のqubitを標準基底測定で測定すると、
上の二つのqubitをこの例の
射影測定で測定した場合と
まったく同じ効果が得られる。
この例の射影測定でね。
二つの結果の確率はまったく同じになり、
測定が上の二つのqubitに与える
影響も同じになる。
これは全然自明じゃない。
それを確認するには分析が必要で、
その分析はここでは示していない。
既に示唆したように、この特定の測定は
後のレッスンで詳しく見ていく。
今のところは単なる例として
捉えておこう。
重要なポイントは、このようなことが
あらゆる射影測定に対して常に可能だということだ。
だから射影測定を導入しても
追加の能力は実際には得られない。
でも射影測定はとても有用な概念で、
シリーズを続けていく中で
射影測定についてよく話すことになる。
このレッスンの最後の部分は、
量子情報のいくつかの重要な制限について、
そしてquantum circuitで
できることについてだ。
最初の制限——制限というよりは
縮退と言った方がいいかもしれないが——
global phaseの問題に関係する。
少し前に触れたやつだ。
global phaseの意味するところの
定義を示そう。
二つの量子状態ベクトルPsiとPhiがあって、
一方が他方に複素数alphaを掛けたものと
等しいとする。
その場合、二つの状態は
global phaseだけ異なると言う。
あるいはglobal phaseを除いて
等価と言ってもいい。
量子状態ベクトルのユークリッドノルムは
一に等しいため、この等式が
成り立ちうる唯一の方法は
この複素数の絶対値が一に等しいことで、
つまりalphaは単位円上に
なければならない。
global phaseだけ異なる
二つの量子状態があって、
状態Phiを測定するとしよう。
標準基底測定でね。
結果Aを得る確率はここの式で与えられる。
PhiにalphaとPsiの積を代入すると——
等しいと仮定しているから
代入できる——この確率が得られる。
alphaが複素単位円上にあることを使って
簡略化すると、この確率が得られる。
これはPhiの測定が結果Aを与える確率だが、
今やこれはPsiの測定が
結果Aを与える確率とまったく
同じだとわかる。
だから二つの状態の異なる結果の
確率には、まったく何も違いがない。
同様の議論から、より一般的に
あらゆる射影測定において
確率は再び同一だとわかる。
つまり測定によっては、global phaseだけ
異なる二つの状態の違いは
統計的な意味でもわからない。
最後に、状態Phiに
ユニタリ操作を適用すると、
代入することで得られるのは
まったく同じ複素数alphaが
状態Psiに同じユニタリ操作を
適用して得られるものに
掛かったものだ。
だから二つの状態は依然として
global phaseだけ異なる。
要するに、二つの状態は完全に
区別がつかないから、
実際には何も違いはない——
ユニタリ操作と測定を行うことで
それらから学べることという
観点からは。そのため、
これら二つの状態を等価と見なす。
あるいは好むなら、これらは単に
異なる可能性のある
同じ量子状態の
ベクトル表現に過ぎないということだ。
最初に言ったように、これは基本的に
量子状態ベクトルによる
量子状態の記述における縮退だ。
いずれにせよ、これが意味するのは
global phaseは単に無視できるということだ——
標準基底測定を記述したときに
実質的にやったようにね。
射影測定として。ちなみに、この縮退は量子情報の
簡略化された記述においてのみ起こる。
密度行列を使って量子
状態を記述するとき、つまりこのシリーズの
第3ユニットでやることだが、そこでは一意な
行列表現が得られる。
すべての量子状態に対してな。グローバル位相の
問題は、量子情報の一般的な記述では
そもそも生じない。
それが量子情報の一般的な記述の
もう一つの魅力的な点だ。
ずっと触れてきたことだが、いずれにせよグローバル
位相に煩わされることはない。
なぜなら、それを無視する
自由を行使すればいいだけだからだ。
グローバル位相という概念を
明確にするための簡単な例を見てみよう。
マイナス状態と、マイナス1倍したマイナス状態があるとすると、この2つの状態は
グローバル位相だけ異なっており、特にアルファはマイナス1になる。
一方、プラス状態とマイナス状態がある場合、これら2つの状態は
グローバル位相だけ異なるわけではない。
これらは直交ベクトルだから、線形独立だ。
2つの量子状態ベクトルがグローバル位相だけ異なると言うことは、
そのベクトルが線形従属であると言うことと同値だ。
だからもちろん、これらのベクトルは
グローバル位相だけ異なるわけではない。
確かに唯一の違いはこのプラス符号が
このマイナス符号に変わることだが、それは
相対位相差と呼ぶものだ。
それはグローバル位相とは異なる。なぜならベクトル全体を
複素数で掛けているわけではないからだ。
これはこれらの状態を区別できるという事実と
整合している。特に、
Hadamard演算を適用して
から測定すると、状態がプラス状態なら0が見え、
状態がマイナス状態なら1が見える。
このレッスンで見る量子情報の次の限界は
複製不可能定理だ。
これが複製不可能定理の
一つの表現で、この特定の
定理の表現はかなり具体的で明確だ。
そのため話しやすくなる。複製不可能定理をより一般的に定式化する方法は他にもあるが、
今はこれに焦点を当てよう。
同じ古典状態集合を持つ2つのシステムXとYがあると仮定する。
その古典状態集合は
0からD-1までの整数からなり、Dは少なくとも2だ。
古典状態の名前が何であるかはあまり重要ではないが、この名前を選ぶことでシンプルに保ちやすくなる。
ここで最も重要なのは、
少なくとも2つの異なる古典
状態があるということだ。言い換えれば、
自明でつまらないケース、
つまり古典状態が1つしかない場合は
考えない。
定理が言うのは、X、Yに適用できるユニタリ演算Uで、Yを
ゼロ状態に初期化した場合に、
Xの任意の量子状態を
効果的にコピーまたは複製できるものは存在しないということだ。
この式を単独で見ると、
XのすべてのPsiという量子状態ベクトルの選択に対して、
UをPsiとゼロ状態のテンソル積に
適用すると、PsiテンソルPsi、つまり
Psiの独立した2つのコピーが得られることを意味する。
それが量子状態を複製できるということの意味で、
定理が言うのはそれは不可能だということだ。
これはcircuitの観点から考えられる。定理が言うのは、
ここで見るように機能するgate またはcircuitを
決して作り上げることはできないということだ。
状態Psiの1つのコピーが初期化されたqubitのコレクションと共に入力され、
Psiの2つのコピーが出力される。
特定の状態Psiの選択に対してはこれができるが、
すべての量子状態Psiに対してこのように機能する
circuitを決して作り上げることはできない。
それが定理の言うことだ。
この定理を証明するのはかなり簡単で、
実際、本質的には私たちが
探している変換が線形ではないという事実に帰着する。
しかしユニタリ演算は
線形だから、うまくいかないだけだ。
もう少し詳しい議論を見てみよう。
標準基底状態、Ket 0とKet 1を複製する
ユニタリ演算Uがあると仮定する。
古典状態0と1は、DがÅ少なくとも2なので
古典状態集合に属さなければならないことはわかっている。
しかし線形性により、
XがプラS状態にある場合、これはこのように書ける。
すると結果はここにある2つの状態の
この線形結合になる。
しかし、それは正しい動作ではない。Uへの要件は
UがプラS状態を複製することだ。
つまり、ここにあるこの方程式が
満たされなければならない。
この2つの状態は同じではないから
うまくいかない。それだけだ。
複製不可能定理についての
いくつかの追加的な補足。
まず、複製不可能定理のこの表現は
ある意味で絶対的だ。
ちょうどこのように機能するユニタリ演算Uは
存在しないと単純に言っている。
だから、何らかの記述方法に関して
これをおよそ行うユニタリ演算Uが
存在するかどうか疑問に思うかもしれない。
その命題の近似になる。近似にはいくつかの
異なる概念があって、それぞれ興味深い
そのうちのいくつかは
このシリーズの第3ユニットで見ていくが、これらの異なる
近似の概念については、
定量的な命題が存在していて、
複製不可能定理はどれほど上手く近似的にクローンできるかに強い制限を課す。
第2の補足として、標準基底状態のコピーやクローンは
確かに可能だ。
例えば、Controlled NOT gateはqubitの標準基底状態をコピーする。
これは
複製不可能定理と矛盾しない。要点は、複製不可能定理の意味でのクローンは
これが単に
標準基底状態だけでなく
すべての状態に対して機能することを要求する、ということだ。
Controlled NOT gateは
例えばプラス状態をクローンしない。
最後に、確率的状態に対しても
複製不可能定理が存在することを指摘しておく価値がある。
ただそれは
人々が話題にしたり気にしたりするものではない。
誰かがランダムに
ビットを選ぶとして、例えば2つの値に確率を
割り当てる何らかの任意の方法で、
そのビットを渡してきた場合、
もちろんそのランダムビットの独立したサンプルを2つ得る方法はない。
確率が何なのか
分からないからだ。
Controlled NOTが
標準基底状態をコピーするのと同じようにビットをコピーできるが、それは確率的状態をクローンするのとは違う。
それをするための情報が
十分にない。与えられたランダムビットからは確率が
何であったか分からない。
ただのビットだ。
確率的状態のクローンが
不可能なのは、量子の場合とまったく同じ論法から導かれる。
クローンは非線形なプロセスだが、確率的演算はユニタリ演算と同様に線形だ。
いずれにせよ、確率的状態をクローンできないのは
驚くことではなく、
量子状態をクローンできないという事実ほど
興味深くはない、
しかし要点は単に、これが量子特有の
現象ではないと観察することだ。
このレッスンで議論する量子情報の
最後の限界は、直交していない
2つの量子状態を完全に識別することは不可能だ、
ということだ。
別の言い方をすれば、
2つの量子状態が完全に識別できるなら、それらは直交していなければならない。
2つの量子状態PsiとPhiの
完全識別とは、それらを
区別する何らかの方法があって、
誤りの可能性がまったくない、ということだ。
quantum circuit modelの観点では、画面に
見えているようにこれを表現できる。
ユニタリ演算Uがあり、それはquantum circuitとして実装できるか、あるいは単にUを抽象的に考えることもできる
ユニタリ演算として、
入力としてUは状態PsiまたはPhiのどちらかを受け取る
初期化されたqubitの束とともに、これはこの識別プロセスを何らかの形で補助するワークスペースqubitと考えられる。
Uが適用された後、先頭のqubitが標準基底測定で測定され、これが完全
識別の部分だ。
入力状態がPsiなら、測定は
必ず100%の確率でゼロの結果を出し、入力状態がPhiなら、
測定は必ず
やはり100%の確率でイチの結果を出す。
Uが適用された後のこれら他のqubitの
状態が何であるかは重要でない。
重要なのは測定から得るこの1ビットだけだ。それが最初にどちらの状態から始まったかを教えてくれるビットだからだ。
PsiとPhiの状態の選び方によっては、このような完全識別が
可能なものもあれば、そうでないものもある。
そして観察することは、
これが可能ならPsiとPhiは
直交した状態でなければならない、
ということで、つまりPhiと
Psiが直交していなければ、完全に識別できない。
では完全識別が直交性を含意する理由を見てみよう。
これら2つの図が表現することを表す
2つの方程式を書き下すところから始める。
状態PsiとともにUを
初期化されたqubitの束に適用した後に得られる量子状態について考えると、
それはここに示した形を
持たなければならない。Pi zeroはこれらすべてのqubitの状態を表す量子状態ベクトルで
先頭のもの以外のものだ。この量子状態Pi zeroについての情報は何もなく、何でもあり得るが、
全体の状態は
このような形でなければならないことは分かっている。なぜなら測定が100%の確率でゼロの
結果を出すことが保証される唯一の方法だからだ。
そして2番目についても
同様の方程式がある。
今回は先頭のqubitが
イチの状態でなければならず、Pi zeroと同様に、
状態Pi oneは何でもあり得る。
Pi oneについての
情報がないことに加えて、Pi zeroとPi oneの関係についても
何も分からない。
知る限り、これらは単なる
2つの任意の量子状態だ。
次にできることは、これらの方程式の両辺に
U dagger、つまりUの共役転置を
両側から掛けることだ。
そうすると、ここに見える2つの方程式が
得られる。
U dagger掛けるUが単位行列になるという
事実を使っている。
だから、どちらの方程式の左辺にも
UもU daggerも現れないわけだ。
さて、PsiとPhiの内積を考えることができる。
これはPsiとPhiの内積に、
L zeroの状態とそれ自身の内積を
掛けたものと同じだ。
なぜなら、任意の状態とそれ自身の内積は1であり、
L zero状態も例外ではないからだ。
2つの方程式を見ると、ここにある式が
ベクトルの内積に等しいことがわかる。
それは2つの方程式で表されるベクトルの内積であり、
特にこれらの方程式の左辺どうしの内積だ。
同様に、この内積をこれらの方程式の右辺で
表されるベクトルの内積として表すこともできる。
なぜなら、両方の方程式において
左辺は右辺と等しいからだ。
というわけで、この式が得られる。これは2つの方程式の
右辺どうしの内積だ。同等に言えば、
最初のものの共役転置を2番目のものに
掛けたものだ。
U掛けるU daggerは単位行列に等しい。
Uがユニタリだからで、消えてしまう。
少し整理すると、これらの内積の積が
得られる。
Pi zeroとPi oneの関係については何もわからないので、
その内積がどんな値かはわからない。
それは謎だ。でも何であれ、Ket 0とKet oneの内積、
つまりゼロに掛け合わせることになる。
最終結果として、値ゼロが得られる。
これがまさに示したかったことで、
PsiとPhiの内積はゼロに等しい。
つまり、2つの状態は直交しているわけだ。
だから、直交していない2つの量子状態を
完全に識別しようとしても無駄だ。できないんだ。
今証明した命題には逆もある。
直交する量子状態は常に完全に識別できる、というものだ。
これはレッスンの前半で触れた事実を使えば、
それほど難しくわかる。
具体的には、PsiとPhiが直交状態なら、
できることの一つは任意のユニタリ行列Uを選ぶことだ。
最初の2列がその2つの状態に
なるようなものを。
これは常に可能であることがわかっており、
このタスクのためにこのユニタリ行列をどう選ぶかは
重要じゃない。
大事なのは、これらが最初の2列だということだけだ。
追加のQubitsは必要ない。2つの可能な状態に
Uを適用するだけで、
2つの可能な結果が得られる。
一番上のQubit、覚えておいてほしいのは一番右のQubitのことだが、
それを測定すると、ゼロかいちが得られる。
どの状態から始めたかによって決まる。
あるいは、ここに見えるように定義された
結果ゼロから1までの射影測定を
考えることもできる。
この場合、測定は実際にはPsiにしか
依存しない。
この測定は、PsiとPsiに直交する任意の状態を
完全に識別する。
この射影測定でPsiを測定すると、
これらの方程式が示すように、
確率1で結果ゼロが得られる。
そして、Psiに直交する任意の状態Phiに対しては、
確率1で結果いちが得られる。
これらの計算の詳細は省くが、
興味があれば、自分で詳細を
確認してみることを勧める。
以上でレッスン3は終わりだ。このレッスンでは多くの内容を扱った。
quantum circuitsも含めて。
内積と正規直交性、射影と射影測定、
グローバル位相が関係ないという事実、
no-cloning定理、そして直交していない状態は完全に識別できないが
直交状態はできるという事実。
第4レッスンにもぜひ参加してほしい。
このシリーズの第1ユニットの最後のレッスンだ。
第4レッスンでは3つの非常に重要な例を扱う。
テレポーテーション、超高密度符号化、
そしてCHSH不等式、またはCHSHゲームとも
呼ばれることがある。
ではまた。